[Musique]
ce terrain accueille d'habitude des
matchs de foot mais de plus en plus
c'est un sport moins connu en belgique
qui se pratique ici
en afghanistan le criquet est un sport
national alors pour ces jeunes hommes en
exil ce match est un moyen de se
remémorer le pays qu'ils ont dû fuir
elle met digèrent les 64 mineurs que con
ce centre d'accueil arrivé sans famille
en europe ce sont des mineurs étrangers
non-accompagnés plus connus ici sous
l'acronyme de ménard
ont remarqué que depuis cette année en
tout cas depuis deux ans plaisir même
qu'un atout majeur de monde en asie en
général mais certaines remarques et la
proportion des ménages l énorme tout cas
on n'a jamais connu ça elle dépasse de
loin la crise et 2015 donc l'agent sont
que dire des structures d'accueil n'ont
pas été préparées cela résultat certains
mineurs se retrouve son tuteur pourtant
en belgique c'est un pré requis à toute
procédure administrative
ce jeune afghan de saison est arrivé il
ya un mois il attend toujours qu'on lui
désigne un représentant légal
j'ai besoin de quelqu'un pour m'aider à
remplir ma candidature à une protection
internationale mais aussi de quelqu'un
qui parlait des problèmes de la vie
quotidienne mais m'angoisse pour ce
tchadien de 15 ans après un exil
traumatisant il s'est retrouvé coincé
dans un vide administratif
on n'attend pas inquiet ça fait presque
trois mois aux quatre mois comme sèche
descente homme était un peu déçu pour
moi ce que je t'ai 600 parents et les
tuteurs
ici pour
certaines choses
c'est le rôle de didier tuteur
professionnels aujourd'hui il est venu
au centre pour aider ces quatre mineurs
à préparer la prochaine étape de leur
procédure d'asile normalement ça va être
bientôt à votre tour gd bien normalement
parce que sur les 46 menad on s'occupe
didier les trois quarts sont afghans
avant qu'on ait tuteur d'un jeune afghan
utilisé c'est formidable parce que
beaucoup de ces jeunes obtenu une
protection
au moins subsidiaire pour ne pas dire
statut de réfugié depuis l'arrivée des
talibans ou juillet et en août
paradoxalement alors que le pays encore
plus instable qu'avant la belgique vous
semblez de dire que puisque il ya un
nouveau régime politique qui apparemment
importe une certaine stabilité ne sait
pas laquelle
eh bien les jeunes son côté de moins en
danger amir khan esmatullah n'apprennent
le français que depuis quelques mois
mais ils tiennent à nous expliquer
pourquoi ils ont quitté leur pays ces
programmes neufs pour les jaunes porte
monnaie
dans le bol des jeunes qui peuvent
prendre les jaunes qui pas les cool
aussi problème est tellement elle y
vient pour moi les maisons beaucoup au
bo gars et moi frère moi un père ma
soeur c'est toute
[Musique]
la procédure d'asile n'est pas la seule
démarche à la charge de didier qui
légalement détient l'autorité parentale
sur ces mineurs à peine sorti du centre
il doit décrocher son téléphone
c'est un propriétaire qui loue un studio
à un menad on s'occupe didier à cause
d'un problème administratif
l'aide sociale n'a pas versé le loyer à
temps vous le mettant en demeure mais il
fait quoi le gamin avec ça
je vais réinterpeller le patron pour
voir si la fiche de paye à des est déjà
sorti deux de son secrétariat social a
vaincu voilà une bonne journée monsieur
oui on va
vous avez ici un propriétaire aux abois
au propriétaire que peut-être vers 20
studios qui louent un prix exorbitant
dans des conditions qui sont parfois un
femme qui vient crier famine parce que
il n'a pas touché son loyer et moi je
dois quasi me prostituer devant lui en
disons que ça va arriver qui doit pas
qui ne doit pas stressés qu'ils étaient
des profils comme celui de didier ne
sont pas si faciles à trouver pour
pallier le manque de tuteur le ministère
de la justice prévoit un recrutement
prochain nous avons régulièrement des
citoyens qui postulent pour devenir
tuteur le plus important c'est d'avoir
des personnes qui ont les compétences
humaines qui ont un intérêt pour les
matières liées à la migration ou liées à
l'enfant qui migrent difficile dans ce
cas de ne pas se prendre d'affection
pour certains mineurs saïd vient de
fêter ses 18 ans mais didier lui rend
toujours visite alors tu dois surtout
pas avoir peur said as ton propre
géographie de lui lire et monsieur je ne
comprends pas ce que vous voulez me dis
là est ce que c'est bien ça que vous
demandez le tuteur 900 cash car il
ressent pour saïd un sentiment quasi
paternel aujourd'hui même dans sa classe
de 4e professionnelle en france est il
pas les libanais belge quoi donc d'après
lui les gars j'ai fini ma mission à 18
heures avec un jeu ont maintenant quand
on est du tort on voit là on travaille
avec de l'humain et donc on laisser un
jeune a 18 ans et un jour c'est très
rare que compass apprend à la majorité
de ses pupilles didier ne perçoit plus
de rémunération mais ce qui perdure
c'est le sentiment de devoir aider ces
très jeunes gens sans famille dans un
pays qu'ils connaissent peu